racing movies those can be fun video
game movies those can be fun too need
for speed so Need for Speed is a new
movie in theaters based off of the video
game yes right need for speed this stars
Aaron Paul he's like the best driver
ever but you wouldn't know it because it
comes from humble beginnings his rivals
Tony Stark's daddies his upper class
really rich dudes I can beat everybody
you know that guy's not as good as Aaron
Paul's Aaron Paul worked for Heisenberg
you're not gonna be better than
Heisenberg sidekick man Heisenberg's
Robin is still cooler than the really
cool douchey rich guy in case Aaron
Paul's character goes to prison for a
couple years and gets out he's like I'm
gonna race in this really secret
underground race to prove my innocence
prove my innocence prove my worth take
Howard Stark down so most of the movies
a cross-country trip he's doing that he
has to make in a couple days in which he
has to avoid the law and not attract
attention while he attracts the
attention of a lot of law can't help
watch the movie ago it doesn't make
sense why would this other rich guy give
this kid his car when he's an ex-convict
it just it doesn't make sense
I'm just saying businessmen don't loan
the really expensive ass rare cars to
ex-convicts they don't do that then that
scene you saw in the trailer where a
chain is linked to the hood of the car
this helicopters flying him over this
Canyon things like that make me think
like when filming this do they actually
link a chain around the hood and just
carry the car or do they create some
special rig inside the car because if
you had to create a special rig inside
the car that means the physics don't
make sense
so which case now it doesn't make sense
to me in which case the movie does I
said stick me out of it it takes me
completely out of the movie and I'm like
and there's other we're
like people on the road are trying to
chase him right first of all we've
established this car is the fastest car
ever and he's the best driver ever
so these douche bags with pickup trucks
and dune buggies are right on his ass
trying to take him down you're like no I
really doubt it I just don't think so
the movie has established that that's
impossible so when that happens the
movie has not made the impossible
possible
but the impossible is now possible in
the movie that established what is and
is not possible in which case that is
impossible
you can't me know ultimately this is
gonna sound weird but the road getting
to the end race is actually more
interesting than the end race itself the
end race is happening and you're
watching it going uhhow's the coolest
parts of the movie are now
if you like the bad guys going to get
screwed either way and Aaron Paul is
gonna walk away from it you know proud
and either way so what's the point
at the end race I just I don't see a
point to the N race this movie isn't
terrible though I mean I walked in this
movie going video game movie
dead-on-arrival
by surprise I enjoyed some of the cool
and it's just it's really light if
you can suspend your disbelief in
everything you know to be logical
everything you know about physics
anything you know that makes sense you
can sit back and watch the movie not
questioning it you'll probably have a
fun time if you're required more than
that you're gonna walk away from this
moving on no that didn't make sense I
didn't maybe you know I assess the movie
is but in the end Need for
Speed isn't terrible it's just not good
enough to be good because what I'm
trying to say is need for speeds
probably a fun time if you're over the
limit yeah and now it's a part this is
Jeremy John's here to tell you do not
drive if you're filling the need for
speed doing my part to be responsible
great question today is a very simple
one what is your favorite racing video
game of all time me burnout revenge I
would slap on Rob Zombie and just burn
steam in that game I just felt better
all the time after every round whatever
your favorite racing game is comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you